[Musica]
scarseggia il pesce così facendo trovato
trovava invece si che ciò il pesce tu
non ce l'hai maledetto maglia viola in
mano non c'è ma che perché le ogni volta
che parliamo di pesci devono esserci
doppi sensi
mi sono messo a pescare per tutto il
giorno ragazzi perché dovevamo avere
delle provviste che ovviamente non
avevamo anche perché siamo su
quest'isola maledetta da 800 episodi per
quale motivo perché pietro non sapeva
guidare una [ __ ] nave e quindi
imbarcata li mezza graziata perché
abbiamo dovuto questo riuscire a casa
con legno quindi l'unica cosa che
possiamo mangiare pesce e non abbiamo
neanche lo you can eat me lo sento
stavolta prendo pesca una scarpa fermo
tutti fermati grazie gesù quando vuoi
pescare una scarpa ma inizia a piovere
no no no no no no è tamat madonna
mazzotta fitti struggo l'esistenza
sinuoso l'aido maledetto ma ciò che
piove di non per pure le balle la pasta
ma vai via
una letizia parte non c'era l'acqua di
sotto ho rischiato di farmi malissimo
fatemi fare una intro recente perché tu
sei fuori che dilaghi un po che fai
schifo
ok ho pescato in tutto questo è un pesce
che hai tu che problemi hai come persona
spiega a milan è chiuso master rinuncia
questo facevano giorno posso finire una
serie con questo elemento cioè
incredibile basta levati la pietra alla
mano pietro levati da pietro e pietra va
bene non è una cosa allora visto che
questo è un po l'ultimo episodio che
affronteremo il vostro boss finale cioè
il leader io ti ho preparato un
pensierino un ricordo un regalo ad arte
per celebrare questa ultima puntata di
naufraghi insieme chissà perché non mi
aspetto niente di buono
vai lì mi
questo è un regalo fatto col cuore
vai ma non in bottoni ma che palle
schifo ma basta che odio scioperi
bottoni non avete ma poi nei fatti 64 di
nuovo quando lei è buttato deficiente e
quel proprio che avevamo solo quello
quando i parenti di regalano le cose
schifose devi far finta che ti piacciono
grazie mille dei portoni 26 stato
aggiunto nel torneo va bene ragazzi
allora facciamo quello che va fatto la
il mio c'è un modo per riparare le armi
novero consensi piovere che figata che
io adoro infiniti si è quasi l'otto l'ha
vinto con infinita mura viene cosi un
meccanico meguid in un meccanico io
praticamente che un amico con quel
soggetto che ha fruttato un po di volte
fa e mai girato nei turni a incudine che
figata che mettiamo ai piedi del tour ma
perche se un deficiente che io dormo
sono già fatto il resto stanotte cosa
non solo ripararti il letto è non solo
riparati l'arco anche ripararmi il letto
aspetta ma posso anche metterci dei
potenziamenti in più ok a figo
il power ha un breaking fantastico
perché non abbiamo fatto subito sta roba
non ce lo devi farlo ma tu sei scemo non
scappo da combatterlo molto prima andrà
a cosa facciamo così almeno siamo
potenziati per il prossimo bossi va bene
dall'atto poi nominare le armi ma si
passò da milan a cui eliminava subito
fantastico e ha finito ma rafficati
credibile come chiamato il tuo loren dai
dai che quando spara le frecce pd con
che mi hai fatto fuori nello scorso
episodio di ogni volta è una goduria
sparare frecce da meno colta che stiamo
andando nell'etere difficile quello ad
attuare quindi occhio all aids
ci siamo sarà difficile trovare questi
cavalieri della morte mi attaccano
ancora sti cosi no no no perché
guardando un pollo aia ma mi hai mentito
sei uno stupido l'innocente allora da
dove dobbiamo iniziare per trovarsi i
cavalieri della morte maledetti un'altra
fortezza in questa atmosfera non questo
è mi sa che anche un po i trafficata
questa fortezza quindi via write
allora facciamo una torcia per
ricordarci la strada ok se no ci però ci
siamo anche occhio dietro occhio dietro
occhio dietro diamo via annio via
andiamo via pietro diamo via cioè non
c'erano neanche così tanto casino nelle
terre di mordor la renault maledizione è
molto più difficile di quanto pensassi
ma c'è qualcosa lì a signore tra dove
guardate la lo vedi
c'è una cena costruzione per questi film
è mai vista wow trovata credo che sia
questa credo sono sti cavalieri neri
spiega mi sa sono gli scheletri quelli
neri gli scritti di humour che ho capito
sia dalla sorpresa sono qualcuno anche
loro due
102 ok set ora mattino non per cento
rispetto a carico e non la troppa do
niente questi dovrebbe fare qualcosa
esatto questi altro fatto una spada ma
le gare non è quella che dice no è no
e quanta probabilità di trovarne una
abbastanza bassa uno scritto uno
scheletro dove quale arrivò poi di
venezia presa eccola qua la ritrovata
maniera quasi dove te lo chiedo perché
l'ho preso prima grande per fare pieni e
mancando familiare com'è che così
capisco è questa qua a destra
prendila with skeletons cal
ok che servono tre stretching e servono
sì ma passiamo inter mela
rimettete la mano non serve a niente non
sai che bello
va bene occhio bim
voleva da me lava lava cosi taglia ma
l'iniziale mi ha fatto malissimo
ok morto ma che lo sbaglio
no niente niente di quanto è difficile
che trovino sta cosa mamma mia c'era
un'altra di quanto spetta che sto
morendo dall'allenamento o che non può
attaccare che si tocca non ti avevano
detto la sensi vento che caga sceso giù
per niente ancora niente
tenevamo qui sopra qua ed un nero line o
che invece play out kcal h spara è da
tanto che la tesi anch'io ho chiuso
l'evento è andata una truffa da
aspettavano a buttare giù vedi sopra
no una maschera del carbone e behrami
perché ha trovato un altro venini altro
carbone in quanto difficile che troppi
non darò bala è molto molto ma che cosa
abbastanza fortunato del carlo ha prima
subito ecco un altro un altro amico
bello in fondo sei andiamo così spaccare
lo spaccato di un altro po da niente
maledizione occhio gasperi non ti ho
visto perché l'hack è male sono nero e
non intendo will smith aiuto che male
che vada chiamate a chiamarla in manette
ok la fanno malissimo e cavalieri neri
20 colpi devono trova maxtor cavalca che
fastidio continuare ad occuparmi carbone
un altro settore molto schietto ore pare
all other ok perché sei morto
sono morto gesù
eccolo dormì vedove dei punti come
scendo da mio piccole che le bisogno di
scendere a me più contenute
thank you eccola qua l'ho recuperata
grazie a dio po fino almeno quella
venire cultura su e ce l'ho ce l'ho
preso no non trovo ancora niente o molto
si ha molto scheletro vai vai ammazzalo
di arrivo intanto no niente verso ancora
un altro grande grande arrivare moriva
rivoglio porca vacca tra due di maggiora
tu non ce l'hai detto io la mia quindi
siamo ok ho la mia quindi la tua più uno
più uno fa due ce l'abbiamo 2 occhio ai
due la tecnologia aiuta grad armi ad
herat in geni tieni perfetto e magari
ora voi 0 a fare qualcosa ma cosa vuoi
che onora che ammazzano mitropa niente
che è colpa mia perché hanno trovato il
web
nel frattempo di prove della sua parte
sì l'ha trovata te lo giuro 333303 in
questo momento mai allora direi che
possiamo tornare alla porta ne abbiamo
tre che figata
bene bene vai vai vai vai vai tu sei un
moto di mente lo sai valore ai grossi
problemi ma ti pare che fai un ponte e
poi all'ultimo non finisci aveva saltato
sente la pigrizia incombe servirebbero
ultima cosa prima di andare a pagare lui
de la soul sand che non avere teme di
prendere quattro blocchi di questa di
prendere subito ma ciliegia miceli
corrida dove ca vacca che spavento di
miss è entrato in faccia mentre vi sono
girato di quadri concerto di esperienza
purtroppo quindi dovrebbe mai l'hai qua
non vorrei essere pessimista ma io ci
siamo persi fumare in elezione ci manca
solo vuoi essere guarda allora aspetta
che arrivo io tipo bear grylls
vedo una torcia di sapri sopra
costruisciti sui piedi occhio che
gelosamente spara se il parlamento
insieme in alto perdiamo tutto e potrei
effettivamente perdere la mia cresima
perché si chiama gold si chiama gas in
spagna non sbaglia chi lo smile lo slime
cioè al massimo beh perché l'ho chiamato
white paper sentire sulle sementi gas si
chiama mike lo chiamo questi va bene ok
dove lo slice da allora io ho visto la
torcia acqua guarda vedi che il sole
torce qui ma e baia buon grado di non
avere trovato la direzione va zio
gasport john smythe bravo bravo dove
aiuto non avendo dico sinistra della
barra smythe squadra formata iap bravo
con sia stato forte e chiaro in cina sia
riuscita di trovare con la strada
perfetto aver letto vai vai vai vai mai
così perfetto no ma perché ma perché
maledizione la maledizione dei polli
incomberà su di noi ha posto metto luogo
nella scelta e così almeno non corriamo
rischi che ciò distruggano loro fatto
prima colpi stare maiocchi mettilo
nell'inventario prendo e metodi non
elementari lo metto diventare va bene ok
ci siamo dormiamo dormiamo basta mio dio
quanto abbiamo faticato qua allora o
spada piccone e pane manca l'arco più
nemico 6 nel tuo nuovo arco segno nuovo
cento per cento ma è un bellaria
infiniti 1 powertrain breaking dire che
siamo messi bene allora o spada piccone
18 di pane e o quegli oggetti provocare
il boss finale come si evoca allora devi
fare ma dove vuoi farlo di cantare anche
stavolta camion style saprà cade sopra
la casa viene qualora ci sei non sono
capace partiamo benissimo guardiamo
molto bene ma dovrei rifarla la roba che
faccio io ma con la soul se ne parlava
di questo genere con la società ok ok a
questo punto dovrei mettere le teste più
guiderà dove ho messo le torce ok non ne
vai
quando metterà in lui
ma attenzione e mongolo scusami
attenzione perché sposerà il videoclip
subito subito quindi siamo pronti
vai come aiuto vero gigante aiuto in
quanto è grosso
pietro montefalco è un capitolo la
nostra casa come l'arezzo le edizioni
miei quattrini e lo vedo porca vacca
come gigante aia confederato somiglierà
d'occhio non potevo si sono fatti
coprirlo fate capire torino guarda molto
visto togliendo gli ho tolto metà vita
aiuto madonna che male che male che male
a chiamare fa malissimo madonna e forti
che escono sport aiuto è morto porical
acqua quanto forze sono separati in casa
e difficilissimo dove riprendere tutte
le cose porcava è fortissimo
l'hack è male come molto anch'io sui
nostri animali sto vedendo la
distruzione i miei occhi che a vacca
aiuto pietro dobbiamo trovare le armi è
circolato per la vita
ma perché è stato andato ammazzare gli
script ma che problemi a police quindi
non lo so però se recuperato bel po di
vita occhio che sta torna ad occhio
stragista di sei e sono qua dietro casa
sta distruggendo tutto quello che
intorno è sparito tutto come frutto
quanto è sparito e mi ha ucciso sono
esplosi i miei oggetti credo che li
l'arco tutta roba del tutto esploso ma
la nostra isola pietro mari decisione
sta tornando al saturn ad occhio damian
arconate la mia onestà
e poi facciamo dove a menarlo a schiavi
ok bravo bravo la madonna mai si è
cacciato di casa aiuto aiuto aiuto
pietro aiuto ho capito che male fa
bastava far politica baila pietro no
vabbè ma fattibile ti giuro fatto cosa
sapete
[Musica]
ovvio che ayala amate gli archi male
beh non è neanche così forte madonna che
porta le manone fortissimo pietro non
vedremo mai difficilissimo e
difficilissimo veramente noi faremo ce
la faremo di non demordere
qui si recuperare se non si recuperasse
la vita dico io beh caro vecchio tratto
delle frecce grandissimo colpisci vai
che c'è la polis qui ma non fare domande
cui piscità min arco e mezza vita e
mezza di trouble che colgo era giovanna
giù che corre e va bene più lontano per
favore non ti vede da qua
ma come sta abbassando tutti i rischi da
me ne approfittiamo per recuperare un
attimo però anche visto al comprando
vita vedi bisogno di narco con i the oc
e o ai piccolo piccolo
questo soprattutto quanto distruggere
anche la terra vabbè dai la sinistra gol
l'hack è male fucili non vi è prossimo
uccelli lo pietro fa male
porca vacca pochissimo dai dai che a
poco il nostro mare dove sto morendo o
una porzione di un secondo ai lo pensino
il resto dove sto
l'hack è male perché male tutti no
search sopra volta l'ha ucciso aiuto
dietro continua senza ne sono volte alla
fine ce l'abbiamo fatta
torna vittorioso o un cuore e mezzo ma
chi ha trovato qualcosa almeno la stella
astenne sotto il mare
ma chi stella nella zona della wizz air
stella è una tua amica si ok è questa
qua prendila avanti noi questa quante
noi qua bianca si nether star
ecco una moneta tipo la wide web sars o
dell'esa va bene saliamo mamma mia cosa
serve tutta questa roba che ci abbiamo
rimesso l'isola per trovare a stai
morendo
no signor ha spiegato con questa cosa
che possiamo fare di me un b con quello
che si mangia nel panino
dopo le il bacon e cosa è un forza fare
il far bene così ci trovano solo regola
salvarci barsa fi non facciamo fare a
far fare io dicevo che se lui a spazio
la nostra casa ma non intendevo tutto
questo spazio la nostra casa loro magro
direzione ha presa d'aria mamma mia che
tiravano i nostri animali ci ha
disintegrato tutto non hai capito quanto
disastro ha fatto quel tizio si dà e
fanno esplodere tanto ma tanto ai a
mahler e proprio ora che enna che nervi
va bè ragazzi dire che possiamo dormire
e domani mattina che forniamo il faro
vai venturi freschino sarei hai aperto
le finestre puoi ridere mi hai fatto
prendere quel maledetto poco per tenerlo
nell'inventario per non perderlo
in vent'anni sono a posto e io sono
morto quindi come è sì luogo ci avevo io
mica scemo l'altro balzano morto 26 è
che ti devo dire era impossibile tenerlo
con la faccia esplodere tutto va bene
quindi l'ultimo obiettivo per poi
scappare dall'isola da trovare questo
per fare il far bene fammi vedere come
si fa il faro adesso serve del vetro e
della dell'ossidiana oltre blocchi qua e
il vetro dove ho anche detto anche due
tornieri vieni qua sotto
questo bay con te e quindi adesso devo
fare una torre mentre lo saprà
teoricamente si deve fare una piramide
con materiali preziosi nel senso che
sotto il big one dobbiamo mettere roba
preziosa esatto dobbiamo fare un 3x3 di
blocchi di ferro ok ok dami è bianco o
ferro oppure anche oro va bene sto
facendo tutti i blocchi il tracciato di
blocco 9 blocchi fammi vedere illustra
min e onnipotente pietro cosa devo fare
lord ridere delle disgrazie altrui bene
e adesso vi sarebbero tre pantere parte
di ferro sono tre blocchi per tre
blocchi ora al centro metid b con buy
prendi così chiamate prendi nota pack è
visto ma che figata incredibile che
pippo seno portale che chiaro va
psichedelica bene perfetto pietro ci
troveranno sono sicuro non possono
trovarci così siamo rimasti per sette
episodi su quest'isola giorni e giorni
senza cibo c'è il pescando solo pesce
pesce marcio xke pietro non sa cucinare
quindi roba brutta abbiamo fatto sette
l'angelo
abbiamo battuto due boss l'ultimo boss
ci ha distrutto l'isola quindi l'ultima
cosa che ci rimane essere salvati vi
prego aiutateci
[Musica]